[Aplausos]
[Música]
Bienvenidos a diario del mundial el
programa de France 24 donde actualizamos
y analizamos el día a día de la Copa
Mundial de la FIFA
Qatar 2022 a continuación nuestros
titulares
descalabro en Qatar Alemania gana cuatro
a dos a Costa Rica pero el resultado no
le sirve para avanzar en un mundial
marcado por la sorpresa segunda copa del
mundo consecutiva que los germanos se
quedan en la fase de grupos lo vivimos
desde doja pero también desde Berlín
España pierde el invicto un gol muy
dudoso le da la victoria a Japón que
frustra la expectativa española de pasar
de primero en su grupo y además
determina la eliminación de Alemania
tenemos análisis
sorpresa también en el grupo F Marruecos
derrota Canadá y ellos se combina con el
empate entre Croacia y Bélgica para que
los africanos terminen de primeros el
reporte es de doja
para analizar el acontecer de cada
jornada Contamos con la presencia de
Octavio saso periodista de la emisora
Blu radio en Colombia Octavio bienvenido
Hola Omar buenas tardes y también desde
doha le damos la bienvenida a nuestra
enviada especial Natalia Ruiz giraldo
que nos trae todos los detalles de
primera mano Natalia saludos
muy buenas noches para ustedes
y debacle para Alemania golea Costa Rica
y muestra sus mejores armas como no lo
había hecho en todo el mundial pero de
poco le sirvió porque en el otro partido
del grupo Japón volvió a sorprender en
el Alemania Costa Rica estuvo nuestra
enviada nuestra compañera Natalia Ruiz
giraldo Natalia cómo se vivió ese
partido Sabiendo lo que estaba
sucediendo digamos en la otra arena en
el España Japón
Así es Omar pues completo Frenesí que
finalmente viene a calmar esta bruma que
nos está rodeando aquí en el estadio el
bate porque finalmente pues estos dos
partidos se disputaban a al mismo tiempo
y comenzaron muy parecidos no con ese
gol primero de morata aquí fue el
encargado de abrir el marcador en el
minuto diez y luego ya fue en el segundo
tiempo donde las cosas dieron un vuelco
completamente
loco se vio una locura aquí justamente
cuando Tejada pues logró empatar el
partido y luego prácticamente unos 12
minutos después llegaría el gol que
adelantaría a Costa Rica aunque fue es
solo algo pasajero gola de Vargas y aquí
fue un júbilo increíble en este estadio
con los hinchas gritando ticos ticos sí
se puede los alemanes prácticamente
callados y pues muy a la espera de lo
que pasaba en el otro partido de hecho
en las pantallas que hay aquí en este
estadio Pues de vez en cuando mostraban
la tabla de posiciones y ahí es donde el
estaba enterando finalmente que Japón
iba primero que era muy posible Pues que
Costa Rica finalmente pudiera quedar
segundo y sacar a los dos grandes a
Alemania y a España esto duró
prácticamente tres minutos porque luego
vendrían ya pues los de los otros tres
goles de Alemania los dos de y el último
de full
Natalia en este partido se vivió el
primer arbitraje completamente femenino
de un mundial de fútbol masculino cómo
estuvo la terna encabezada por Stephanie
Pues en realidad fue una muy buena
prestación Omar stephanieve capaz que
supo pues manejar muy bien todo el todo
el partido de pronto un par de acciones
sobre todo en el primer tiempo que
Podrían haber sido un poquito discutidas
pero que en realidad no fueron de su
responsabilidad sino de las dos fuerzas
de línea que la acompañaron pero no hubo
ningún tipo de decisión polémica o que
pudiera ser demasiado discutido y que
hubiera dado quizás un giro por completo
a este partido Así que una muy buena
presentación hay que decir también pues
que los jugadores tuvieron Pues también
todo el respeto hacia hacia de hecho
hizo sentir también Su autoridad en la
cancha hubo un momento en que después
del primer gola de aves pues eh estuvo
que anda el Weston que no quiso entregar
el balón rápidamente y ella llamó a los
dos jugadores al orden para que ya
pudiera retomar el juego Así que fue un
muy buen comienzo para las mujeres aquí
en un mundial de fútbol arbitrando y
también muchísimo respeto por parte de
lo público no no hubo ningún tipo de
chiflidos Así que fue una buena manera
de de este momento histórico no
solamente para papá sino en realidad
para para las mujeres y para el mundo
del fútbol en general y ya les contamos
Cómo se vivió en doha pero también
impulsamos cómo ha sido la reacción en
Alemania concretamente en Berlín Desde
allí nos relató el corresponsal de
France 24 Thomas
la eliminación de Alemania sin duda un
golpe muy fuerte para una selección que
hace apenas ocho años era campeona del
mundo pero que desde entonces ha estado
en una muy profunda crisis esa crisis es
quizás una de las razones por las cuales
los alemanes no han estado siguiendo tan
de cerca esta copa del mundo en
comparación con torneos anteriores pero
no es la única razón los temas políticos
relacionados con los derechos humanos en
Qatar el boicot de algunos bares y
establecimientos públicos y un mundial
que se realiza en pleno invierno han
contribuido a ese ambiente poco emotivo
de parte de los alemanes y ni siquiera
en televisión los alemanes parecen estar
siguiendo el mundial muy de cerca los
ratings han estado comparativamente
Bajos en comparación con torneos
anteriores Y en ocasiones incluso
películas de suspenso han tenido más
espectadores que partidos del Mundial
Sin embargo a raíz de esta eliminación
es muy probable que en los próximos días
haya un debate muy fuerte en Alemania
sobre rumbo que deberá tomar la
selección tras esta debacle en el
mundial de Qatar muy duro escuchar eso
en un país tan futbolístico como
Alemania y Octavio Este es el segundo
mundial consecutivo en el que Alemania
se queda en la fase de grupos Cómo se
explica que suceda esto con una
selección que tiene varios de los
mejores jugadores del mundo y que además
tiene como una columna vertebral de
jugadores que que están juntos
permanentemente que son los del Bayern
Munich Sí yo creo que que umar tiene que
ver con el hecho de que están en medio
de un de un proceso de transición aunque
no lo parezca por un lado está la
despedida de jugadores importantes como
Thomas miula por ejemplo que seguramente
hoy jugó su último partido en un mundial
Y seguramente su último partido con la
selección nacional y por el otro lado la
aparición de jugadores con mucho talento
como Hades por ejemplo o Leroy sane o el
propio Navy Pero hay un proceso en el
medio hay un hay una ruptura en el medio
y evidentemente hoy a Alemania le faltan
varios de los jugadores de jerarquía que
tuvieron en algunos otros mundiales por
ejemplo hoy terminó entrando sobre el
final del partido
jugaba en la selección hace tantísimo
tiempo y que fue la revelación o el
hombre que ayudó a Alemania a conseguir
el título en Brasil 2014 ha pasado mucho
tiempo desde ahí y evidentemente eso
muestra una un digamos un una ruptura
entre el seleccionado alemán y y la
creación de de jugadores que puedan
tener esa jerarquía para jugar en eso Yo
estoy seguro que también el hecho de que
nos contaba el el corresponsal con
respecto al rating y a todo el
desinterés de la gente en Alemania
también tiene que ver con la forma en
cómo perdió Alemania el primer partido
evidentemente si Alemania hubiese ganado
el primer partido y se hubiese generado
una Comunión con la gente seguramente el
país hubiese seguido porque estamos
hablando de uno de los países más
importantes del mundo en cuanto al tema
futbolístico hoy me parece un mar que se
ha dado la gran decepción del mundial
digamos la caída de Bélgica la caída de
de otro tipo de selecciones en medio de
Dinamarca no tienen ningún
ninguna comparación con la caída de El
tantas veces campeón Alemania y la forma
repetimos en cómo queda afuera porque
hoy que haya goleado a Costa Rica es
prácticamente un accidente luego de que
una selección costarricense que incluso
lo puso a sufrir durante mucho rato del
partido terminará cediendo ante ante la
potencia alemana Pero el hecho estaba en
en Cómo se fue eliminado Alemania del
mundial y y que esto tiene que
significar una una ruptura una antes y
un después evidentemente en el en el
ciclo alemán me se me parece mucho más a
la forma en como Italia también rompió
su ciclo luego de ser campeón en 2006 y
España también perdió su España perdió
su invicto Y eso implicó que no podrá
cumplir el objetivo de terminar primero
de grupos Japón con una victoria basada
en un gol que dejó muchas dudas ha
terminado en la cabeza de su llave lo
que deja España las puertas del Duelo
con Marruecos en octavos de final y le
preguntamos Octavio Más allá de la duda
con respecto con respecto a ese gol de
la Victoria qué imagen está dejando
España que pasó de la goleada de la
Euforia de ese siete a cero contra Costa
Rica después de un empate y ahora
termina perdiendo contra Japón sí
sorprendentemente lo de hoy fue fue el
peor partido de España en el mundial
sobre todo por porque en el primer
tiempo daba digamos a entender España
que iba a dominar el partido
tranquilamente que que iba a ganar el
encuentro que lo iba a manejar pero me
parece que España lo sobró en algún
momento del partido es decir No es que
le falta el respeto al rival pero por
momentos se sintió muy Superior y el gol
del empate de Japón Me parece que viene
de de un error que se genera por eso por
empezar a sobrar al rival sabiéndose
Superior y cuando pasan ese tipo de
cosas te despiertan de una cachetada y
eso fue lo que terminó haciéndole Japón
a a la selección española que luego no
pudo levantarse que estaba metida en un
shock que por más de que lo intentaba
evidentemente Japón se fue cerrando muy
bien y lo terminó complicando aún deja
una imagen muy agridulce por más de que
Japón o por más perdón de que España se
clasificará igual que tenía que pasar
una debacle para que quedara fuera que
por momentos Incluso se dio porque con
el dos a uno de Costa Rica quedaban
afuera de España y Alemania Y eso sí
hubiese sido la ruptura total de las
quinielas pero pero en un momento del
partido Supongo que España al enterarse
de cómo iba el otro resultado también le
bajó un poco a la carga y aunque no nos
parezca umar España con la derrota
termina eliminando Alemania evitando
Brasil evitando Argentina y jugando con
Marruecos Ahora la próxima fase y no con
Croacia evidentemente ningún equipo
quiere perder pero no le sale tan mal el
negocio a la selección de Luis Enrique
Sí definitivamente y volviendo al tema
de ese gol que que parece que en un
momento antes de concretarse el gol hubo
un momento en que la pelota abandonó el
campo según lo muestran algunas de las
Tomas digamos podemos hablar de que hay
unos automatismos o una dependencia de
la tecnología en este mundial que es que
está evitando que criterios humanos
decidiendo sobre situaciones como estas
Si no existiera la tecnología y si no
existiera el lugar uno entendería eumar
que pasen estas cosas y uno dice Bueno
la pelota salió el árbitro no la vio
termina pasando la pelota y el gol pasó
en Alemania 66 ha pasado tantísimos
lugares que evidentemente uno entendería
que no pasa nada ahora con tanta
tecnología con un chip dentro de la
pelota con el bar con todo lo que sucede
es imposible que nadie nos explique Qué
pasó en esta jugada o sea cómo la
terminan corroborando si en principio
nosotros vimos en la mayoría de las
repeticiones que la pelota había salido
Entonces no puede pasar esto cuando
después en un partido te pitan un upside
por una uña es decir Alguien tiene que
explicar tecnológicamente hablando qué
fue lo que sucedió en esta jugada de
todas maneras lo que me parece es que
España va a seguir soñando con los
asiáticos porque rápidamente recuerdo el
mundial de Corea del Sur y Japón cuando
España jugó contra Corea del Sur y
cuando le pitan una pelota que no había
salido a Joaquín En aquel momento y
termina eliminando España también en ese
partido frente a Corea pero pero la
tecnología tiene que ser muy clara Omar
si pitan una uña un brazo un codo en una
posición adelantada tienen que explicar
qué pasa en este tipo de jugadas si la
otra gran sorpresa que nos deja este
jueves es el hecho de que Marruecos haya
terminado al frente de su grupo por
encima de Croacia y con Bélgica
eliminada ese resultado previsible
frente a Canadá nos lo relató más
temprano el otro enviado especial de
France 24 Juan pupiales
hay celebraciones en Marruecos Los
Leones del Atlas se impusieron A Canadá
por dos a uno para clasificar octavos de
final y además como primeros de grupo
Los africanos saltaron al campo con
mucha convicción sabiendo que podían
ganar a Canadá ya le habían ganado a
Bélgica fue así como se adelantaron con
un tanto de sillas después de un grave
fallo del portero canadiense
posteriormente en el circo culminó a la
perfección un pase de hakimi para poner
el 2-0 y tanto de la tranquilidad en es
decir que se convierte en el primer
jugador de Marruecos que marca en dos
las marcó en Rusia 2018 y marca también
aquí en Qatar Al filo del Descanso llegó
un tanto para Canadá gol en propia
puerta de ayer que hizo que saltaran los
nervios para los marroquíes que en la
segunda parte entregaron la pelota para
los canadienses pero sufrieron sufrir
Para volver a unos octavos de final Como
lo hicieron ya en 1986 cuando los
eliminó Alemania con un golazo de los
dar Mateos al final del partido
Marruecos es la primera selección árabe
que avanza a los octavos de final aquí
en este mundial de Qatar primer mundial
en un país árabe y lo hace aquí en el
estadio de altumama un estadio que como
Ven a mis espaldas tiene una forma de
gafilla una forma una prenda de vestir
una especie de gorro muy típico del
mundo árabe mucha celebración mucho
simbolismo para los marroquíes que son
una importante hinchada aquí en doha
Octavio con ese partido termina la fase
de grupos para Canadá que es otro de los
equipos que va a ser anfitrión dentro de
cuatro años qué evaluación podemos hacer
de estos tres México Canadá y Estados
Unidos ya cumplí esta fase si es un
golpe muy duro lo de Canadá se convierte
en seis partidos en la historia de los
mundiales no ha podido ganar Ninguno me
parece que realmente fue muy triste Cómo
se despide de Canadá pensaba que iba a
tener mejor participación sobre todo
después del primer partido lo de México
lo que veníamos diciendo si México
hubiese podido jugar el partido frente a
Polonia cómo le jugó a Arabia Saudita
tendríamos otra historia seguramente con
el seleccionado mexicano Y todavía tengo
la impresión de que Estados Unidos le va
a ir mejor Estados Unidos es el equipo
de los tres que tiene más talento
individual si pueden dar ese paso
Estados Unidos va a ser seguramente la
mejor selección de Concacaf
y el empate sin goles en el Duelo entre
Croacia y Bélgica marcó la eliminación
de los Diablos Rojos un equipo que hace
cuatro años había sido tercero en el
mundial de Rusia que tenía varios de los
mejores jugadores del mundo en sus
posiciones como de brun y courtois
solamente citar dos y aún así quedó
eliminado en la fase de grupos y se
ubica tercero en su llave ese partido
también lo siguió Natalia Ruiz y le
preguntamos Natalia qué podemos decir
podemos decir que tal vez fue el mejor
partido de Bélgica a pesar de que fue el
peor desenlace para ellos
Ay omara difícil decir que fue el mejor
partido de Bélgica porque no ganaron que
era lo que tenían que hacer el día de
hoy en todo caso para tener chances
esperando lo que pasara en el otro
partido entre entre Marruecos y Canadá
pero lo cierto Es que vimos a a una
Bélgica completamente desdibujada a lo
largo de todo este mundial Solamente
pues eh pudieron ganar un partido frente
a Canadá y solamente pues por una mínima
diferencia Así que complicada la
situación de de esta edad dorada
finalmente de estos belgas que salieron
incluso pues eh casi se lo sorprenden en
el segundo 17 es el primer tiempo
Croacia con una Bélgica que finalmente
con muchísimos problemas también en
ataque empezaron con con mertens y de
bruyne y finalmente salió él para darle
paso a lucaco lukaku que tuvo cuatro
oportunidades claras para marcar a gol
una de ellas estrelló en uno de los de
los postes pero digamos negados En todo
caso los Diablos Rojos para poder
encontrar finalmente la posibilidad de
abrir el marcador en este partido y
sobre todo también dejando a los croatas
armarse muy muy bien incluso hacer
jugadas pases muy cerca ya dentro de el
área misma de los dedos Así que muchas
preguntas que quedan en este sobre este
equipo este equipo que en estos últimos
días pues ha sido también centro de de
muchas preguntas de muchos rumores sobre
problemas de unidad de este equipo de
hecho el comienzo del partido los vimos
en algún momento Eh pues hacer esa esa
especie de de rondó de abrazarse entre
ellos tratando tal vez de acallar
también todos los rumores que se han
escuchado de de problemas de altercados
entre bertongunyan entre courtois entre
allá con lukaku que al parecer tuvo que
venir a separarlos y ahora pues está
Esta generación dorada que finalmente se
queda sin Roberto Martínez que ya dijo
que no continuaría al mando de los Red
deadles Así que muchas cosas que cambiar
ahora en Bélgica Y seguramente una
renovación que debe llegar un como lo
que está sucediendo también con Alemania
Natalia Mil gracias por su aporte
seguimos mañana con mucho más de este
mundial
Claro que sí Mañana nos vemos
seguramente con otro día de infarto
Octavio Mil gracias También a usted
mañana nos reencontramos
Y estos resultados están dejando
definidas dos nuevas llaves de octavos
de final España como comentábamos antes
era el rival de Marruecos un
contrincante complicado pero alude como
decía Octavio el encuentro con Argentina
o Brasil en cuartos y a Japón Le tocará
chocar contra Croacia
hasta aquí Diario del mundial los
invitamos a acompañarnos de nuevo mañana
con un especial de media hora analizando
este final de la fase de grupos Mientras
tanto sigan con la programación de
France 24
[Música]